earlier this week we brought you
reporting from minneapolis that's the
city still reeling from the george floyd
riots of two years ago
businesses in many cases still haven't
reopened and the city is experiencing a
massive crime wave 39 percent rise in
murders compared to 2019 and residents
there they have no idea if their city is
ever going to be rebuilt in certain
neighborhoods
heck people don't even feel safe
shopping anymore
yesterday at the mall of america just
nine miles outside of minneapolis random
gunfire had panicked families scrambling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
minneapolis is ground zero for
minnesota's decline and it's represented
this district none other than elon omar
yes instead of fighting for citizens to
be safer she's fighting defund the
already depleted police force
now finally it turns out that the
community is sick of her antics the star
tribune and even uber lefty mayor jacob
fry have now endorsed her primary
opponent a guy named don samuels
but is another democrat really the
answer joining me now is jim schultz
who's running to unseat another radical
in the state attorney general keith
ellison
now jim you call ellison the political
godfather of elon omar
why and when did this state go so
radical
well it's pretty recently laura and it's
great to be on with you you know keith
ellison you know preceded ilhan omar in
congress he was elected in 2006 and then
she succeeded him and she he very much
is her political godfather they're fully
aligned on on the issues they've
embraced these radical defund the police
policies that have led to that
extraordinary violence that that you're
talking about
well i was so saddened because as you
may know i spent quite a bit of time in
minnesota every year i've been going
there for 15 years for the summer and
it's just so beautiful it's such a
wonderful state in the in the twin
cities minneapolis it's just such a it's
a vibrant community never felt unsafe
there and then
the lawlessness came in after floyd and
people wonder if there's any way to turn
it around now
you're right i mean it's been a painful
few years in the state you know i grew
up in the state i'm a fifth generation
minnesotan and i think my i feel it and
minnesotans feel generally that we're
losing the state we have known and loved
and it's because of these radical
policies embraced by people like keith
ellison and ilhan omar and our terrible
governor tim walls that have led to this
to us to this current point i mean i
call it a man-made disaster it's a
man-made disaster that is descended upon
our state and we have to turn it around
immediately
now in endorsing omar's opponent
obviously you're running for attorney
general but her seat is where you know
her district is where all the violence
took place they said omar often appears
disconnected from her district and
unwilling to work with leaders such as
fry
when asked by the editorial board for
thoughts on cedric alexander omar said
she did not recognize the name and had
no opinion even though his nomination to
the high-profile public safety role was
prominently reported by local news
outlets um so jim basically saying
she doesn't really care about the
district it's more about her own public
profile and burnishing that
absolutely i mean she seems to spend all
of her time in washington these days
she's completely disconnected from the
community and frankly keith ellison is
frankly disconnected from the community
you know if they were connected to the
community they would know that there's
areas of north minneapolis that have
become a shooting gallery there's areas
in minneapolis and st paul where you
just you in any given day you might be
uh be uh be carjacked or otherwise and
so they end up embracing these policies
that have led to such you know
extraordinary crime and violence in our
state and so these are you know two kind
of limousine liberals that have um led
that have embraced policies that have
led to incredible violence and
destruction in our state yeah good for
the criminals bad for the people
thank you good luck in your race hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else